Allyson you have six Emmys which is  unstudied and I'm just curious yeah Hana  do you ask her to well you know you're  you ask her yeah I yes I have I've seen  I've seen her Emmys and they are  incredible they in fact they're a pretty  good weapon it's the most dangerous  award they give out is the other it's  like got nine deadly points on it  it isn't though allison is an incredible  host and when she invites me over for  her one of her many fabulous parties she  lets me fondle her amazing yeah everyone  likes to do fake any speeches with yeah  she's very good a tattoo she I'm very  good at it it's really good I do that  with hair brushes you don't need the  actual award right I just hold any  object in the house I know I'll hold a  cat and say I'm so honored that the  accountant is like  [Laughter]  you